I'm in the city of kupiansk it's one of
the cities that was key in recapturing
by the Ukrainian forces as part of their
counter-offensive but since we've been
here we can hear a lot of incoming
strikes a lot of outgoing strikes too
clearly it's not yet been completely
under control over there you can see a
zed mark from the Russian occupation one
of the vehicles you can also see a huge
amount of damage that's being caused in
the last couple of weeks during this
offensive obviously the ukrainians had
to use strikes to come in targeting
Russian positions but we've been told
that as the Russians have been leaving
they've been striking back even as we've
been standing here today we've heard the
sound of drones that's an outgoing sound
we've heard the sounds of drones
overhead followed by incoming strikes
towards near this position we've had to
move inside for cover if you take you
around here and this is the main police
station in the town it was used by by
Russian forces while they were occupying
the place and now police and other
investigators including forensic experts
are inside trying to work out what
happened in their whether people were
tortured we know people were definitely
detained the conditions inside are
pretty Grim it's the start of yet
another war crimes investigation here
all the while as the war is still being
fought yes the ukrainians have pushed
the Russians back but clearly the
Russians haven't gone away completely